TYT gets four million from Buddy Roemer
and firm 20 million from other investors
and fundraisers YouTube even gave us a
chunk of 300 million dollars in their
news initiative I mean I think it's only
fair we do the work I think we're
entitled to question today okay of
course everybody's hated right we've
talked about this on the left right
every there is hypocrisy everywhere no
one lives up to a perfect standard but
do you find that leftists today
progressives find it especially hard to
play by their own rules when it affects
their pocketbooks have you been
following the Young Turks saga and
shanks vehement opposition to unions in
the enterprise also how soon did you
have to change your pants from pissing
yourself laughing this story I want to
be very clear here Jeng Jeng queer is
not just like an T specific he's an t
you didn't in the Young Turks period
across the board maybe part by the way
the political attack against him because
he's running for office I get that but I
don't care some context before we get
some clips last week of course the Young
Turks announced the workers announced
that they were going to be planning to
unionize so before we get to the
response and spoiler alert I think you
can know that they they weren't exactly
super thrilled this should be a moment
of Glee for the Young Turks The Young
Turks specifically chanc considering
their rhetoric on unions and
corporations for I guess not decades
that a decade they should be thrilled
workers want to unionize they want to
say hey maybe we'll have more leverage
if we all unite by ourselves they're
just gonna fire us and get somebody else
though filled a job but if we're United
together well that's in this in a way
part of the marketplace where we then
use our collective power and leverage it
against the employee do to make sure
we're a government union or if you don't
have a government union you don't have
collective bargaining and you want to go
into your boss and say alright I'd like
to pay rates you're gonna have
absolutely no ability to do that
the only way that any boss would take
you seriously whether it's a private or
a public place is whether you could
bring everybody in together I mean when
you have a chance all right
running this it might be to their great
interest to make sure that unions are
incredibly weak throughout the country
the death of Antonin Scalia might have
in adverse Southern California very good
ramifications for American Union the
reason unions make sense in especially
in very large corporations is because
you have uneven power any one worker has
very very little power against through
giant corporation is 5000 work number
the millionaires to billionaires crazy
number like 5,000 get great results
because of that why'd you pick 5,000
workers there are not many companies
that have 5,000 workers why don't you
pick I don't know 50 because if you look
at the Bush tax cuts on how they would
affect businesses of course Young Turks
in the top tax bracket I just let me
keep sorry and by the way I want to be
clear I defend shank we Gers right to
not have as employees unionize of course
I should never but if people here
unionize um you know you'll you I mean
you won't actually be fired but come on
don't show it for the next day you know
you did it's just and I would love to by
the way before we get into the details
Young Turks compare Ledger's and books I
guarantee you we pay these workers here
more than you do the young choice cuz
you have something like 80 employees so
they should be thrilled old Lee Jake
Weger and they're not here I think we
have at overlay from his tweet and
according to heaven in post this just
came out today in a tense meeting with
employees
shank Weger argued that a union doesn't
belong in a small News Network
struggling to make profits he said that
if there had been a union at the network
it would not have grown the way it has
his talk was at times emotional the
staffer said with we throwing his papers
to the ground at one point in chastising
an employee
yeah yes I understand I'll keep in mind
the artists market they have I think
like 80 something employees right do we
have an overlay here yes this is if you
look at what's so important here argued
a union doesn't belong in a small news
network struggling to make profits he is
just arguing for himself what he has
been railing against as a macroeconomic
argument from the right for her decades
people don't listen if a business that
is trying to grow is being overtaxed
over-regulated if you have workers with
unrealistic demand with the union and
unions obviously hold a lot of sway in
the Midwest of the point where they're
no longer competitive like we've talked
about the the educational sectors unions
we talk about the SEIU we've talked
about the United Auto Workers Union he's
basically take Weger in defending
himself from his workers unionizing he
you could read this quote and attributed
to Milton Friedman he's borderline
making an anti-union video for Prager
you you can see coming down the breaker
you corporations in being Pro Union and
it's not even if you look at the
articles it's not even a consideration
that people can unionize at the Young
Turks company down the block
everything's are right except to work at
the use why would body feel by the way
hit the notification bell if you're
subscribed on YouTube because
subscriptions don't mean a whole lot hit
all notifications and please do consider
joining mom Club at laterthe credit calm
/ mutt club because we we are not funded
by a foreign caliphate or investors and
this is another point it's weird because
the Young Turks they have a lot of money
right a part of the new 300 million
dollar the the news spending initiative
is going to be funding them they've
received millions of that Buddy Roemer
Republican I think it was 27 million
dollars from was it al Jazeera always
like this this matters they have a lot
of money far more than we have by the
way we'll get into that in a second why
is this all important because just
listen to what what she has to say when
talking about politicians and corporate
money like this isn't just an out of
on tax quote his veins all day because
to champion the work like The Young
Turks is just short of having a hammer
sickle and fist logo and then once it
was like you know not a fist but like
hey how about a high five over there
never I'm not even close
here's another talking about corporate
money they never talk about corporate
power so they say oh unions good because
I want the union's donations I want the
uterus Union voters etc but I don't
wanna take any risks as unions are
fighting with the corporate power right
and so when you keep taking money from
those same corporate interests the do I
am I convinced that you're really gonna
breathe fire on those guys why don't you
know what I'm listening you have my
curiosity my friend another think about
it post weaker said himself he was
quoted saying that he's a strong
supporter of unions especially at large
corporations that aren't sharing profits
with their workers especially so Jake
Wow do you share profits no we do here
you know those bonuses that you get with
a pretty sizable yeah because we don't
know what the profits are going to be we
actually do share profits here I would
love to have a look at your books and
see what these employees are being paid
and if they're great workers out there
who aren't died and we'll let this we
are hiring here at ladder was go yeah
you can do the work we're not Union but
you'll be paid better and treated more
fairly another quote
the reality is we're in a precarious
position weaker said we're in a digital
media landscape where almost no one
makes money or is sustainable
really first up now this is your excuse
personally right on a macro level your
pro-union but not because not you
because your company's too small with
only 84 employees and you're not guess
what we have 15 employees total no
venture capital we are entirely
sustainable and Young Turks by the way
you supported us being entirely
demonetized so that's an uphill battle
we don't have what is your Excuse with
over 30 million dollars in funding and
shooting at Google Studios for what's
your Excuse how are you not sustainable
it is remarkable to me what we have 20
million foreign investors millions from
Buddy Roemer over 80 employees it is
remarkable to me the lack of
self-awareness here and that they're
doubling down oh yeah oh yeah they're
just digging himself than that dish
doubling down
more auntie it's something else still
also we've never taken I think this is
remarkable to me we've never taken an
investment from anyone asked me how much
I own a vlados car how much unit 100%
100% so I can make these decisions we've
always had licensing agreements or
partnerships already have with the blaze
where they can handle back-end and
software and they have a new app up now
by the way that's great and you get
people like Dave Rubin and all these
other shows over there at the blaze but
no one has ever come to us and giving us
20 or 25 million certainly not a foreign
caliphate and saying well hopefully we
get our money back in ten years we've
never taken on that kind of financial
burden we have fewer employees we have
obviously as you know Young Turks
greater traffic they need right now and
we are entirely sustainable so the
justification is predicated on well
listen we can't unionize because we
haven't made enough money and nobody's
making money online not at what a second
we are funded 100% by how they meet what
are you doing that they need a union now
I get I understand where he's coming
from by the way I'm not a big think you
even served a role at one point in this
country but not anymore and I do agree
with what he's saying they wouldn't be
able to afford a union they wouldn't be
able to grow that is what small
businesses and big businesses all
business good business they argue you
over taxes you overburden us or with
regulations we won't have that money to
reinvest this is another thing when they
talk about profits an amazon paying
nothing into it's not true you are using
the exact same justification only less
honest that other big corporations use
to not be paying exorbitant mountain
from taxes this is another thing too
like we've talked about liberals who are
successful financially you don't live
like liberals right they don't live like
leftist certainly not as it deals with
finance do you think that anyone in
Southern California
they're writing in more money to the
government yeah yeah somebody put
another million dollars on top of that
say now they wouldn't because of the
system what about when Barack Obama was
president you didn't want to throw the
first black president a few extra job
yes if you could avoid all those
loopholes that'd be great yeah okay so
I'll do away with this right all these
rules are for them that don't have huh
yeah I don't think that [ __ ] Weger
should have to have a union I want to be
very clear defending his right but the
hypocrisy No
no bounds and I would very much if Young
Turks wanted to have a third party
company look at a comparable as to what
percentage of since apparently the
interest owners in profits
what percentage go to employees here
versus there what's fair pay who's being
treated more fairly it would it would
bring me great joy but I don't think
it's going to happen so there was a
negotiation today I guess between the
union heads or as Chang we garage them
no longer employed here of course thank
God we just we actually have exclusive
footage I believe of that meeting today
all we're looking for is our fish TYT
gets four million from Buddy Roemer firm
twenty million from other investors and
fundraisers YouTube even gave us a chunk
of three hundred million dollars in
their news initiative I mean I think
it's only fair we do the work I think
we're entitled to what would you people
consider a fair I mean a tiered profit
sharing initiative alright what mister
Uighur means is that your demands are at
least somewhat unreasonable that's right
let's see so you didn't invest in the
creation of the company you didn't take
any risks you're employed and you're
getting paid accordingly that's right
okay what about a raise for all the
extra work we do and what extra work
with heavy we have to light mr. Jenkin
it takes a crew of at least ten people
four hours and we have to cover half the
mall what at this moment they see that
ball
listen listen extra work would have to
be quantified by tangible examples of
labor outside of the parameters of your
contract none of that would meet that
criteria that's right that's absolutely
right beyond the contract what about all
of the search algorithm scrubbing motion
search scrubbing yeah sir he has a
search scrub all the results for
Armenian Genocide - that's [ __ ] yeah
and then he makes an essay on air that
he's addressed it and move on but he's
never invested did it happen though what
happened the Armenian Genocide so health
care and overtime at two and a half
three and a half and dental we can do
that you know the drill just click one
of these other videos in a box playing
up here and I mean by there's an actual
box I don't of course mean that in the
feminine it's a sewer but that of course
I don't mean box because men can have
boxes too and I don't mean to say box I
just that men can there's like a DC
outlet an AC outlet and they can be
either one that they choose depending on
electrical current or that charge of
ions I think